[Music]
well donations are needed though it may
not traditionally be the time to give
through donations for those in need
three square is asking for your help so
its workers and its volunteers serve
more than a hundred thousand people a
year and that's through a different 150
different partners and right now the
need is really high as we just said
jeremy j ford in the newsroom with the
details
that's right the food supply at three
square food bank warehouse is down and
in a time of inflation they have even
more people asking them for help three
square says all pantries are seeing
between 10 and 20 percent increases in
people asking for help
whenever there is some type of
impact to the economy we absolutely
always see a growth in the number of
food insecurity
three square ceo larry scott says to
keep the more than 100 000 people a year
fed donations need to keep coming
they're always in need of meat proteins
and produce and dairy they're the three
principal items that every household
needs because he says food insecurity is
a curable problem i think that's a great
reason to think that they should have no
neighbor
that's hungry
now anyone who is looking to donate to
the pantry can go to eight newsnow dot
com and find the link in this story to
threesquare dot org for more information
jeremy j ford live local now
all right jeremy thank you for that well
for those in need of food assistance
outside of three square there are
several other resources available to you
now that includes the snap program
otherwise known as food stamps now wic
is also another option it offers
supplemental nutrition for women infants
and children as well as health and
social service referrals
maine